foreign 's going to hang this
Foundation is The Saga of Harry Selden
and his followers on their Epic Quest to
Save mankind
Harry is a mathematician who predicts a
series of crises that will result in the
end of humanity
brother day brother Dusk and Brother Don
known as the Empire rule the galaxy with
an iron fist our world will live on
your worlds will not
if I don't know they're headed for
Destruction
they feared Harry because he could
forecast the future the Empire will fall
Interstellar Wars will be endless
nothing we do can prevent this
we can shorten the Dark Ages that follow
Harry enlists A Gifted Prodigy named
Gail done it to help him build the
foundation a standalone civilization
that will preserve Humanity amidst the
crisis
a young Gale the future now rests on her
shoulders
the coming Generations will have
something to build upon a foundation
Harry and his followers are exiled by
the Empire and sent to distant planet
Terminus to build the foundation
Terminus I've never even heard of it
seasons are extreme
there'll be hardships refreshing Rock
long nights no trees for shelter Against
All Odds the foundation flourishes
but the Empire now fears it could soon
become Obsolete and tensions between the
two Nations become explosive war with
Empire is inevitable because under the
genetic Dynasty there is only one voice
the Empire will stop at nothing to
preserve its very existence
they'll destroy the foundation and
anyone who supports them
[Music]
we need salvor Harden who are you
Warden of terminus her mission is to
protect the foundation and to preserve
Harry selden's plan of prosperity for
this new generation but the Empire
remain intent on crushing the foundation
children
Gail dornick has been reaching out to me
I have to find her as the foundation
faces imminent attack Gail's messages
leads Salvo to go looking for her
and as the two women finally meet the
shocking truth becomes clear they're
from two different Generations
my name is salvor Hardin I'm your
daughter
[Music]
the peace and to pay a dear price